bruce wayne
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
my family has a history of philanthropy
but as far as i can tell you're not
doing anything
the riddler
is asking for you
the killer left this for the batman why
is he writing to you
you came
i've been trying to reach you
good there's latest it's all about the
wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats i have a thing
about strength
the bat and the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend to yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
how am i part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruised
away
all these years
you lied to me alfred
we all have our scars bruce you're still
away
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know he's up with
delaney
who are you under there
what are you hiding selena don't throw
your life away
don't worry honey i got nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied
it's your violence you may find
justice
the answer's justice
come on vengeance
[Music]
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
you